i'm talking with anna shuzanovska of the
european commission hannah we're here in
warsaw and you're going to be talking
about the various plans for broadband
across europe let's start by asking how
are we doing with our broadband
deployment at the moment
we are making progress
as of the latest numbers europe is
covered with fast broadband
at 62 of its territory for the
households
that number is quite impressive and the
dynamics behind it is encouraging
but we do worry about the development in
rural areas which is falling behind as
of today only 18 of rural hospitals have
access to fast internet
so 62
is a pass mark in most in most
examinations um but are you confident
that we can get that high can we bring
up the rural threshold to to achieve
this target
well the two aspects um first we set a
target for 2020 we still have a few
years to go
at the same time we worry that the speed
targets that were set in the digital
agenda for europe may not be enough
today we estimate that very shortly a
family
or a small business may be needing more
than 30 megabits per second
of its internet needs
but obviously we need to continue
working towards that goal
there are three ways in which at the
european level we can make a difference
we can make a difference through policy
through regulation
and through financing
now on the finance side and just before
you go this will be a very interesting
thing to tell us about you're going to
be outlining a little bit tomorrow about
the fundamentals of the younger thinker
plan can you can you just take us
through those for people who aren't
fully aware of what it entails
absolutely but perhaps before we do this
let me shortly recall the two other
sources of financing which are already
at the table yes please
at the european level we have connected
europe facility which has a broadband
element it is very small it was heavily
reduced in the last financial
discussions but it is open
to accommodate broadband projects which
may have financing needs as long they
have innovative business models
and they bring something that we could
replicate
for precisely more difficult more rural
areas in europe
there is also a considerable amount of
money much more than ever before within
the structural funds the structural
cohesion funds which some not all of the
european countries will benefit from
from now until 2020.
in our most recent estimates and these
are not final numbers there will be over
five and a half billion euros for
broadband throughout europe
but the really big surprise came within
the investment package
you may recall that mr juncker when he
presented his political priorities to
the parliament said digital single
market which needs to be connected
and
the investment in infrastructures and
these infrastructures are transport
energy and broadband very clearly
broadband is confirmed within european
policy as one of the key vital
infrastructures for the future of europe
i will not walk you through the
financial details because that might be
um perhaps a little tedious but what is
important is that with a relatively
small amount of money at the european
level
we can propose a guarantee
for the financing in europe which will
leverage from the private sector
an enormous sum of money which is
estimated at 315 billion euros
for these
infrastructures for smaller projects
there will be a dedicated pillar within
the facility to deal with smes and mid
caps some of the most dynamic and most
attractive broadband projects including
fiber projects would fall into this
mid-cup category so there will also be
beneficiaries
in the future of the juncker package
so there's some really good
opportunities there for people that are
committed to investing in broadband
most definitely um
the opportunities will come now that the
financing is available but
the two to tango uh
you can offer
financing but you need to have projects
that will actually prepare business
plans and will ask for that financing
in many cases people will very easily
assume that they need to to get grants
in order to
take these projects off the ground in
our experience that is not always the
case
and in some cases a blend between a
grant and a financial instrument may be
the best solution
for the financing it
aligns much better the public and
private benefits that come from fiber
the connectivity brings obviously money
to the operator people pay for
connectivity
but it also has a number of
non-monetizable benefits
like access to culture like access to
services the reduction of costs uh the
ability to do things at the distance the
fact that you do not have to
you know to actually travel in order to
get to something or have access to
something
these are incredibly uh good benefits
especially for the rural societies but
they will not be easily monetizable
within the project hence this alignment
of public and private interests is of
key importance and that is the reason
why we support that development
at all levels of government european
national and regional
so we're going to have some very
interesting years ahead of us by the
looks of it thank you very much for
talking to us that was really really
interesting and uh good luck with the
talk tomorrow thank you
so a very interesting viewpoint there
europe is getting there but is it
getting there fast enough